This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Roman, what prescription drugs do you take? Do you take Jernavax? This is Sean Cole, everybody. He's an old friend of mine, a friend of the show. Or extensor? Do you take extensor? I don't think I want to discuss, you know, like... Rezaiflex? What is going on?
这里是 99% 隐形。我是罗曼·马斯。罗曼，你吃什么处方药？你吃 Jernavax 吗？各位，这位是肖恩·科尔。他是我的老朋友，也是节目的老朋友。或者说 extensor？你吃 extensor 吗？我觉得我不想讨论，你知道，比如……Rezaiflex？这到底是怎么回事？
Ask your doctor about Ex-Demvy. Ask your doctor about Nixplanade. Ask about Ropatha. Ask about Nucala. Ask your doctor about Kaplata. Okay, Sean, why are we talking about this? So the reason I'm sitting here with you today can pretty much be boiled down to the Seinfeldian question, what is the deal with pharmaceutical brand names?
向你的医生咨询 Ex-Demvy。向你的医生咨询 Nixplanade。咨询 Ropatha。咨询 Nucala。向你的医生咨询 Kaplata。好了，肖恩，我们为什么要谈论这个？所以今天我和你坐在这里的原因，基本上可以归结为那个宋飞式的疑问：制药公司的品牌名字到底是怎么回事？
It's like watching TV in the middle of the day can make you feel like you've had a partial stroke that scrambled half the words on the screen, which is ironic considering that that's probably what some of the drugs they're advertising are supposed to prevent. Once monthly ebbglis is a treatment that can be used with or without topicals. Dupixen can help you stay ahead of exos. Ingra. Femzelexelix. Cobenfi.
就像大白天看电视，会让你觉得好像中风了一半，把屏幕上的一半字都给打乱了，这真具有讽刺意味，考虑到他们宣传的某些药物本来就是为了预防这种情况的。每月一次的 ebbglis 是一种可以与外用药联合使用或单独使用的疗法。Dupixen 可以帮你保持领先。Ingra。Femzelexelix。Cobenfi。
Prishti. Phrasek. Maybe we don't need a pill for everything. You can say that again, Keenan Thompson. Well, for managing weight, there's Wagovi. It's funny that Keenan did a real pharmaceutical ad, given that he was also in this Saturday Night Live sketch about a fake hormone supplement for women. There's a new drug for gals over for... It's called for J.
Prishti。Phrasek。也许我们不需要什么病都吃药。基南·汤普森，你这话真没说错。嗯，说到体重管理，有 Wagovi。真有意思，基南真的拍过一个真正的制药广告，鉴于他也曾出演过周六夜现场的这个小品，内容是关于一种针对女性的假荷尔蒙补充剂。有一款针对……以上女性的新药。它叫 for J。
I think it's forgerid. Whatever, just dance. So we all laugh about these drugs, but the question becomes, why do they all sound like Star Trek villains? Is that by design? Is it necessary for some reason? Is it simply wrong-headed on the part of the marketers? I mean, those are a lot of questions,
我觉得是 forgerid。管他呢，跳舞吧。所以我们都对这些药大笑，但问题是，为什么它们听起来都像《星际迷航》里的反派？这是有意设计的吗？某种原因上这是必须的吗？难道纯粹是营销人员脑回路不对？我是说，这有太多的问题，
but do you have some answers for those questions? Yes, I got to the bottom of it. And I'll just say, underneath the noisiness of the names, is not just a logic that you'd never guess is in operation. In a lot of cases, there's, I know how this is going to sound, an actual poetry going on that I never imagined. And that I now want everybody else to be thinking about the next time they see one of those ads. That's a big claim when you're talking about brand names of drugs. I'm, okay, but just hear me out.
但是你对这些问题有什么答案吗？是的，我弄清了事情的真相。我只想说，在这些嘈杂的名字背后，不仅有一种你绝对猜不到的运作逻辑。在很多情况下，我知道这话听起来会怎样，有一种我从未想象过的真正的诗意。而且我现在希望每个人在下次看到其中一则广告时，都能去想想这一点。当你谈论药品的品牌名称时，这是一个很大的论断。我，好吧，但请听我把话说完。
We'll see what you think of the end. But just to start at the beginning. Hello. Scott? Yes, Sean. Hi, how are you? This is Scott Piergrossi, who is in practically every article you read about pharmaceutical brand names. And there's a reason for that.
我们会看到你对结局有何看法。但我们先从头说起。喂？斯科特？是的，肖恩。嗨，你好吗？这位是斯科特·皮尔格罗西，你读到的几乎每一篇关于药品品牌名称的文章里都有他。这都是有原因的。
He's the head of creative at the Brand Institute, which is kind of a clearinghouse. They help name more than 75% of the new drugs on the market in a given year. 75% one company. Yep, at least according to them. 75% of both brand names and generic names too, which are even longer and wilder sounding, as you know. They have a separate department for generics, or not. Non-proprietary. They get upset when you say generics. Non-proprietary names.
他是 Brand Institute 的创意负责人，这里有点像个信息交换所。在给定的年份里，他们协助命名了市场上超过 75% 的新药。75% 都是一家公司？是的，至少根据他们的说法是这样的。不仅是品牌名，连通用名也是 75%，如你所知，通用名听起来更长、更离谱。他们有一个专门负责通用名的部门，或者说非专利名。当你叫它们通用名时，他们会生气的。非专利名。
But we are focusing on the brand names, the Brand Institute names. Can I also respectfully correct you and say it's just Brand Institute? I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Yes. Lose the The, it's cleaner. That's right. That's right. Scott's been at Brand Institute for more than 20 years. And I just asked him to, you know, take me through the process from the beginning. Like, where do they even start naming a drug? Have you ever seen the movie Brain Candy?
但我们关注的是品牌名，也就是 Brand Institute 的名字。我能冒昧地纠正你一下，说它就叫 Brand Institute 吗？对不起。对不起。是的。去掉那个 The，更清爽。没错。没错。斯科特在 Brand Institute 工作了二十多年。我只是请他，你知道的，带我从头了解整个流程。比如，他们给一种药物起名字时是从哪里开始的？你看过电影《脑力激荡》吗？
No. Should I? You should see it. Absolutely. This is a Kids in the Hall movie. That's Kids in the Hall, the sketch comedy troupe from Canada. And Brain Candy was about a new antidepressant drug that came to market.
没有。我应该看吗？你该看看。绝对应该。这是一部《喜剧小品秀》的电影。就是《喜剧小品秀》，来自加拿大的素描喜剧剧团。而《脑力激荡》讲的是一款上市的新型抗抑郁药。
Hmm. So, but they have a scene where the marketing guy comes into the boardroom, and he tells the story of how he thought of the name. Okay. I was driving around last night in my $62,000 car, and I'm trying to think up a name for the drug. And suddenly it hit me. The name?
嗯。所以，但他们有一个场景，营销人员走进董事会，讲述他是如何想出这个名字的。好吧。昨晚我开着我那辆 62,000 美元的车兜风，我想为这种药想个名字。突然灵光一现。名字？
No, a bird had hit my windshield. When that happened, I got depressed. Not you, Cisco. Yeah, even me. But as soon as I got depressed, I got undepressed. Because as I was cleaning the gleaming guts of that bird off my windshield, I thought of the name for the drug. And he says, Gleeman X. And everyone does like a slow applause.
不，一只鸟撞了我的挡风玻璃。当那件事发生时，我抑郁了。不是你，思科。是的，甚至连我。但只要我一抑郁，我就不抑郁了。因为当我正把挡风玻璃上那只鸟闪闪发光的内脏清理干净时，我想到了这种药的名字。他说，格利曼 X（Gleeman X）。然后每个人都开始慢动作鼓掌。
And it's the opposite of how it actually works. How it actually works is much more rigorous. and time-consuming. They meet with the client, the advisor or Amgen or whomever, kind of get a sense as to what they're thinking. And from there, Brand Institute assigns a small team to come up with an initial list of like three to 500 ideas on their round. 500 names. That's a lot of brainstorming for names that will not get used. It's amazing. It is. And at that point, the job is pretty much just figuring out which ones are actually viable and good enough to test out with the client.
这与实际情况完全相反。实际情况要严谨得多，也耗费时间得多。他们与客户（辉瑞或安进或其他公司）会面，大致了解他们的想法。从那以后，Brand Institute 指派一个小团队，在他们的第一轮中想出一个大约三到五百个创意的初始列表。500 个名字。对于那些不会被采用的名字来说，这可是大量的头脑风暴。太惊人了。确实如此。而到了那个阶段，工作基本上只是找出哪些名字切实可行，并且足够好到可以拿去给客户测试。
It's funny because clients will say, just give me an easy to pronounce name and we'll call this a win. And then we present a slide, let's say, of 25 and we'll be lucky if we get to retain two of them. Oh, really? They are all solely easy to pronounce and the client just like, nah, I just don't like it. And I'm like, but that's what you ask for. Just remember that.
这就很有趣，因为客户会说，只要给我一个容易发音的名字，我们就认为这成功了。然后我们展示一份幻灯片，比方说 25 个名字，如果我们能保留两个，那就算我们走运了。哦，真的吗？它们明明都挺容易发音的，但客户就会觉得，呃，我就是不喜欢。然后我就想，但这就是你要求的啊。只要记住这一点。
That's what you asked for. Because why don't they like those ones? Like, what is it when they say now? They can't see it. They can't say it as the product. It doesn't fit. And how are they generating these ideas in the first place? Like when they're coming up with all these ideas, where are the ideas coming from?
这就是你要求的。因为为什么他们不喜欢那些呢？比如，当他们说“不要”时，到底是怎么回事？他们看不到它。他们没法把它当作产品说出口。它不合适。那他们最初又是如何产生这些创意的呢？比如当他们想出所有这些主意时，这些主意是从哪里来的？
Well, historically how it worked was everybody was just sort of foraging omnivorously, anywhere and everywhere for different combinations of words and letters. Magazines, foreign language dictionaries, another company I read about, so not Brand Institute, but a competitor. So they sometimes leaf through cowboy dictionaries and surfer dictionaries. What's a cowboy dictionary? I looked it up. There's one from 1968 called Western Words by Ramon F. Adams.
嗯，历史上它的运作方式是，每个人都在各种地方，无所不包地四处搜寻，寻找单词和字母的不同组合。杂志、外语词典，我读到过另一家公司，所以不是 Brand Institute，而是一家竞争对手。所以他们有时会翻阅牛仔词典和冲浪词典。什么是牛仔词典？我查过了。有一本 1968 年出版的、由雷蒙·F·亚当斯（Ramon F. Adams）编写的书叫《西部词汇》（Western Words）。
I see. A little hauss is soon curried. I'll take your word for it. Brand Institute has also started using an AI platform called Brandy. Cute. That's just helping out with the initial phase of the process. Scott says a lot of the work is still done by humans. You might explore types of names like palindromes or end.
我明白了。A little hauss is soon curried（小马易刷，意即小事易办）。我信你就是了。Brand Institute 还开始使用一个名为 Brandy 的 AI 平台。真可爱。这只是在流程的初期阶段提供帮助。斯科特说很多工作仍然是由人类完成的。你可以探索各种类型的名字，比如回文或。
anagrams. One of the more healthful exercises we do is we try to get the client to state, like if it's on the cover of Time magazine, for example, what would the headline say? And then we actually might even try to mold that expression into a name. Hang on. So you would try to take that sentence. Yeah, so let's say a drug alters your course in life, alter course. So that name is... I want a drug that does that, by the way. If I could take alter course, boy, oh boy. Altricorce.
变位词。我们做的最有益的练习之一，就是我们试图让客户陈述，比如如果它上了《时代》杂志的封面，头条会写什么？然后我们甚至可能会尝试将这种表达重塑成一个名字。等等。所以你会试图把那个句子……是的，比方说某种药改变了你的人生轨迹，alter course。所以这个名字就是……顺便说一句，我想要一种能做到这一点的药。如果我能服用 alter course，天哪，天哪。Altricorce。
Or they could look at the drug and say, okay, what is the hopeful outcome of taking this thing? And then explore that from a bunch of different angles. So, for example, sleep aids. They could say, okay, this is a drug that helps you stay asleep through the night. Or this is a drug that leaves you feeling refreshed in the morning. Same section of the drugstore, two different ways of looking at it. So, for example, there's Lunesta, a drug that Scott's company named.
或者他们可以看看这种药，然后说，好吧，服用这东西充满希望的结果是什么？然后从多个不同的角度去探索。例如，安眠药。他们会说，好吧，这是一种能帮助你整晚保持睡眠的药。或者这是一种能让你在早晨感到神清气爽的药。药店的同一个货架，看待它的两种不同方式。例如，有 Lunesta，这是斯科特的公司命名的一种药。
The reason Lunesta works is because of the lunar imagery. The suffix, Esta, has an inference of restorative sleep. As in C Esta. Ah, okay, very cool. See what they're doing there. But really, the lunar is what anchored it. So nighttime sleep. Within the category, you have Ambien.
Lunesta 之所以起作用，是因为它的月亮意象。后缀 Esta 带有恢复性睡眠的推论。就像 C Esta。啊，好的，非常酷。看看他们在那里做什么。但实际上，月亮才是它的基石。也就是夜间睡眠。在该类别中，还有 Ambien。
What is it, Ambien? It's AMBN. Good morning. So that's the good morning. Then you have newer products. It's like Belsamra. That's a beautiful night's sleep with Belsamra. Bell, Sommis, which is sleep in Latin.
那是什么，Ambien？它是 AMBN。早上好（Good morning）。所以这就是早上好。然后你有更新的产品。比如 Belsamra。那是 Belsamra 带来的美妙一夜好眠。Bell，拉丁语中的 Sommis，意思是睡眠。
Then there's other sources of little name building blocks. They might grab a few letters from the generic name of the drug or the active ingredient. For example, bupropion hydrochloride. That's the active ingredient in the antidepressant, wellbutrin. And then sometimes the name is derived from the science of how the drug works. A lot of cancer drugs are like that, Scott says, because the audience is really more the doctor than the patient in those cases.
然后还有其他小型命名构建模块的来源。他们可能会从该药的通用名或活性成分中抓取几个字母。例如，盐酸安非他酮（bupropion hydrochloride）。那是抗抑郁药威博隽（Wellbutrin）中的活性成分。有时，这个名字源于该药作用机制的科学原理。斯科特说，很多抗癌药都是这样的，因为在这些情况下，受众实际上更多的是医生而不是患者。
So oftentimes we want to highlight what's unique about that product from a scientific standpoint because that'll resonate with oncologists. And about half of new cancer therapies are derived from the mechanism of action, so the science behind the drug. That is what the drug is actually doing
所以通常我们希望从科学的角度突出该产品的独特之处，因为这会引起肿瘤学家的共鸣。大约一半的新癌症疗法都源于作用机制，也就是药物背后的科学。这正是药物实际在做的事情，
and to what part of you. So there's this one drug called Imdeltra. It's I-M-D-E-L-L-T-R-A. Mdaltra is a DLL-L-3 immunotherapy. Well, of course. I mean, everybody knows about that. So the double-Ls and the tru suggesting three is so intentional to represent the mechanism of action of the product, quite elegantly. And if Scott Pyrr-Grosey sounds ever so slightly defensive about the name M-Deltra,
以及针对你身体的哪个部位。所以有一种药叫 Imdeltra。它是 I-M-D-E-L-L-T-R-A。Mdaltra 是一种 DLL-L-3 免疫疗法。嗯，当然。我的意思是，每个人都知道这个。所以双 L 和暗示数字 3 的 tru 是如此刻意，以相当优雅的方式代表了该产品的作用机制。如果斯科特·皮尔格罗西对 M-Deltra 这个名字听起来有一点点防御性，
it's because another drug nameer I talked to did not agree with him. It satisfies a meaning, but look how it looks, and that doesn't really look that good. M.DELTRA. It's hard even to say. Okay, so who's this? I am Arlene Tech. I have worked in brand naming for 30 plus years, most of those, naming pharmaceuticals. Arlene is kind of a legend in pharmaceutical branding. And once I learned a little bit about her in her background, I couldn't not reach out to her to get her perspective on how prescription drugs get their names.
那是因为我采访过的另一位药物命名专家不同意他的看法。它满足了一种含义，但看看它的外观，其实看起来并没有那么好。M.DELTRA。甚至很难说出口。好吧，那么这位是谁？我是阿琳·特克（Arlene Tech）。我从事品牌命名工作 30 多年，其中大部分时间都在为药品命名。阿琳可以说是医药品牌命名界的传奇人物。一旦我了解了她和她的背景，我就不得不联系她，听听她对处方药如何获得名字的看法。
And does she sort of predate the Brand Institute style of naming? Yeah, she's like an OG. And unlike Brand Institute, with its teams of 15 people or whatever, the places Arlene's worked, people tend to tackle projects on their own. And just to give you another picture of how drug names are invented, there's this one drug she was assigned back in 1992 that was for benign prostatic hyperplasia. enlarged prostate, basically, which makes it difficult to pee. In trying to figure out what to name this drug, Arlene ran a focus group with a bunch of urologists. And this one doctor in particular said something that stuck with her. It was at the end of the group, and I asked the doctor, what's it like when the drug worked and the guy got well?
她算是比 Brand Institute 那种命名风格更早吗？是的，她是元老级人物。而且与拥有 15 人左右团队的 Brand Institute 不同，阿琳工作过的地方，人们往往都是独自应对项目。为了让你对药物名称是如何发明的有另一个了解，1992 年她曾被指派过一种药物，用于治疗良性前列腺增生。基本上就是前列腺肥大，这会导致排尿困难。为了弄清楚该给这种药起什么名字，阿琳与一群泌尿科医生组织了一场焦点小组座谈会。特别是其中一位医生说了一句话，让她记忆犹新。那是小组座谈的最后，我问那个医生，当药物起作用并且患者康复时，那是什么感觉？
And the doctor said, visualize a strong stream. A strong stream of urine. Yeah. So when I was home and I was writing the notes up, I thought to myself, well, a strong stream, that would be vigorous. And the first thing I could think of that was stream like that was Niagara. No. Yes. So I put vigorous plus Niagara equals Viagra.
那个医生说，想象一下强劲的射流。强劲的尿流。是的。所以当我回到家写笔记时，我心想，嗯，强劲的射流，那会很有活力（vigorous）。我能想到的第一个有那种水流感的名字就是尼亚加拉（Niagara）。不会吧。是的。所以我把“充满活力”加上“尼亚加拉”等于“伟哥”（Viagra）。
Oh, my God. I know. I met the woman who named Viagra. She gave me her pen. I'm going to keep it forever and ever. But wait a second. So Viagra is for erectile dysfunction, not like the enlarged prostate that makes it hard for you to pee. So what is that about?
哦，天哪。我知道。我遇到了给伟哥命名的那位女士。她把她的笔送给我了。我要把它永远永远地留着。但等一下。所以伟哥是用于勃起功能障碍的，而不是像那个让你排尿困难的前列腺肥大。那到底是怎么回事？
It is. And this is where this naming business gets even more complicated. Super interesting trick of the industry, just to digress here for a second. So Arlene came up with the name Viagra for this drug to treat prostate enlargement. But for a lot of complicated reasons, they didn't end up using the name Viagra for that benign prosthetic hyperplasia. drug. And as far as Arlene knows, they just held on to the name. It's true that companies can bank names in certain circumstances and use them later when a better fit comes along. And around that same time, Pfizer was testing a completely different drug, which had nothing to do with the prostate,
确实是。这就是这个命名业务变得更加复杂的地方。这里顺便扯开话题，讲一个这个行业超级有趣的小把戏。所以阿琳为这种治疗前列腺增生的药物想出了“Viagra”这个名字。但出于许多复杂的原因，他们最终没有将“Viagra”这个名字用于那个良性前列腺增生的药物。据阿琳所知，他们只是把这个名字保留了下来。的确，公司在某些情况下可以把名字存起来，等以后遇到更合适的时机再拿出来用。大约在同一时期，辉瑞公司正在测试一种完全不同的药物，它与前列腺毫无关系，
that drug was supposed to treat angina, which is chest pain due to a heart condition. And the test was very successful. Everybody was complying with it. And some of the guys came back and asked for more. Because, well, it didn't work very well for angina. It did have this crazy side effect. I think the medical term for it is lumpy trousers. And so they thought, well, that would be a much better way to sell this drug if it did that. And they tried to do the whole thing right. They tried to have a focus group. A focus group to name their new miracle erection drug. And the names that came up just weren't that good. They were either too overtly sexual.
那种药物本应治疗心绞痛，也就是心脏病引起的胸痛。测试非常成功。每个人都在按要求配合。一些男士回来后要求更多的药。因为，虽然它对心绞痛没多大用处，但它确实有一个疯狂的副作用。我想它的医学术语叫“裤子鼓包”。所以他们想，如果它能做到这一点，那将是销售这种药的一个好得多的方法。他们试图把整件事做好。他们试图组织一个焦点小组。一个为他们的新奇迹勃起药命名的焦点小组。想出来的名字就是不够好。它们要么过于露骨地色情。
And then some of the names were just not male enough. If you want to sell a drug to Treaty D, it should have a pretty masculine name. And they just so happened to have the one that Arlene thought up stored away. So they went with that. So how does it feel to have named Viagra? Different. Different than having not named Viagra. Well, as my husband always used to say,
而且有些名字的男性气概还不够。如果你想卖药来治疗 ED（勃起功能障碍），它应该有一个相当阳刚的名字。他们恰巧把阿琳想出来的那个名字存了起来。所以他们就用了那个。那么，给伟哥命名是什么感觉？不同。跟没有给伟哥命名过不同。嗯，正如我丈夫过去常说的那样，
say I'm married to the Viagra woman. That could mean a lot of things. Yes, it could. Well, I have also told people that I have a one-word resume. You know, what's funny about that story is that it really is a lot more like that scene in the kids in the hall movie where the guy comes out with Glemen X. I mean, she was just like trying to think of a name for a drug. And then this thing happened and it made her think of another thing. And it led her to the name Viagra.
说我嫁给了伟哥女。那可以意味着很多事情。是的，确实可以。嗯，我还告诉过别人，我有一份只有个单词的简历。你知道那个故事有趣的地方在于，它真的很像《喜剧小品秀》里那个家伙带着格利曼 X 出来的场景。我的意思是，她当时只是想给一种药起个名字。然后发生了这件事，让她想到了另一件事。并引导她想出了“Viagra”这个名字。
It really is much more like that, yeah. So why can't all drugs, you know, have that same approachability? Like, Vagra is a very approachable name. Lunesta is an approachable name. But why aren't they still? Like, when you started, you started naming all these things like Skrillex or something, you know. Scrillix is a DJ. Okay.
确实更像那样，是的。那么为什么所有的药，你知道的，不能都有那种平易近人的方法呢？比如，Vagra（伟哥）是一个非常平易近人的名字。Lunesta 是一个平易近人的名字。但为什么它们现在不是这样了？比如，当你刚开始的时候，你开始给所有这些东西命名，比如 Skrillex 什么的，你知道的。Skrillex 是个 DJ。好吧。
I think you mean Skyrizzi. Okay, Skyrizy. And, you know, Wagovi, whatever. Like, how do we get to there? Okay. So just to start back in time a bit, even farther back from when Arlene. named Viagra. So the big bang of pharmaceutical naming, as Scott Piergrossi calls it, comes in 1988 with the
我想你指的是 Skyrizi。好吧，Skyrizy。而且，你知道，Wagovi，随便啦。我们是怎么变成这样的？好吧。所以为了回顾一下历史，比阿琳给伟哥命名的时期还要早得多。正如斯科特·皮尔格罗西所说，制药命名的大爆炸发生在 1988 年，
introduction of Prozac. That was the first real blockbuster name. It's short, punchy, and it was all about marketing, as opposed to even indicating what the drug did. It was what they now call a blank canvas or empty vessel type name. Obviously, caught the public attention, became a household word. The guy who named it, David Wood, is now in the medical advertisement. Hall of Fame.
百忧解（Prozac）的推出。那是第一个真正的轰动一时的名字。它简短、有力，而且完全是为了营销，甚至都不是为了表明这种药物的作用。它是他们现在所说的空白画布或空容器类型的名字。显然，它吸引了公众的注意力，成为了家喻户晓的词。为它命名的人大卫·伍德（David Wood），现在已经进入了医学广告名人堂。
There's actually a medical advertising Hall of Fame. Of course there's a medical advertising Hall of Fame. David Wood died in 2007. And Arlene was really a protege of his. She worked really closely with him. Basically, I think he was trying to do a name that was
居然真的有一个医学广告名人堂。医学广告名人堂当然是存在的。大卫·伍德于 2007 年去世。而阿琳确实是他的门生。她与他合作得非常紧密。基本上，我认为他当时试图做一个半抽象的名字。
semi-abstract. Everybody knew that the word pro meant something positive. He were for something. And the Zach was simply a syllable that woke people up. It's like zap, zang, zip. Well, the K sound on the end, Zach, had a sharpness to it. You know, a sharp sound might indicate something that was more targeted.
大家都知道“pro”这个词意味着积极的东西。你支持某种东西。而“zac”仅仅是一个能唤醒人们的音节。就像 zap、zang、zip。嗯，结尾的 K 音，zac，有一种尖锐感。你知道，尖锐的声音可能表明更有针对性的东西。
So that year, 1988, only 17 drugs were approved by the FDA for therapeutic use. So 17 prescription drugs that needed brand names. And that number has just trended upward over the years. So last year, almost 50 new drugs hit the market. Number of letters in the alphabet, still 26. And like, why are there so many more drugs being approved now? Just sheer growth in the industry, for one thing. More and more drugs being developed, especially with cancer.
所以在那一年，即 1988 年，美国食品药品监督管理局（FDA）仅批准了 17 种药物用于治疗用途。因此，只有 17 种处方药需要品牌名称。这些年来，这个数字一直在向上攀升。所以去年，将近 50 种新药上市。字母表中的字母数量仍然是 26 个。而且，为什么现在有这么多新药物获批？一方面，仅仅是行业的纯粹增长。越来越多的药物被开发出来，特别是在癌症方面。
It was a big push on that front. And then a few other reasons that, believe me, are too wonky even for this show. I'm going to try not to take that personally. Please don't. Meanwhile, the Scots and the Arlenes of the world are trying to accomplish something that in this climate just gets harder and harder. I mean, in every case, they want to come up with something totally new if they can manage. A singularly unique name is the goal. Why?
在这方面有很大的推动力。然后还有其他一些原因，相信我，对这个节目来说都太深奥了。我尽量不把这当作针对我个人。请不要这样。与此同时，世上的斯科特和阿琳们正试图完成一件事，在目前的这种气候下，这件事变得越来越难。我的意思是，在每一种情况下，只要他们能做到，他们都想出一个完全崭新的东西。独一无二的名字是他们的目标。为什么？
Trademarkability, for one thing. And just plain marketability. They want the product to stand out. But the main factor driving this ceaseless crusade for nominal innovation, Roman, is the FDA. Huh. And so why does the FDA do this? Like, what are the rules? So two big things to focus on here.
一方面是为了商标注册的可行性。还有纯粹的市场化潜力。他们希望产品脱颖而出。但推动这场对名义创新进行不懈追求的主要因素，罗曼，是 FDA。哦。那么为什么 FDA 要这样做呢？比如，规则是什么？所以这里有两个重点需要关注：
Number one, what a drug seems to be promising. The FDA doesn't want a name to sound like, oh, this is some miracle drug. So no big claims in the name. I'm sure you're familiar with FlowMax. Sure. I don't remember what it does. FlowMax is for BPH. That is benign prostatic hyperplasia.
第一，药物似乎在承诺什么。FDA 不希望名字听起来像，哦，这是什么奇迹药物。所以在名字里不要有夸大的承诺。我确信你对 FlowMax 很熟悉。当然。我不记得它是干什么用的了。FlowMax 是用来治疗 BPH 的。也就是良性前列腺增生。
That same enlarged prostate condition that was the very first inspiration for the name Viagra. So maximum flow. God. Flow max. Simple, right? Simple. So that name was approved in the late 90s, I believe. and that name is an example of one that probably today would be more challenged.
就是最初激发“Viagra”这个名字灵感的那个前列腺肥大病症。所以是最大流量（maximum flow）。天哪。Flow max。很简单，对吧？很简单。所以那个名字是在 90 年代末获批的，我相信。而且这个名字就是一个例子，放在今天可能会受到更多质疑。
Because, and this is me speculating, I have no data to say this, but based on the guidance, you know, what is maximum flow, right? What is that? I know how to determine maximum flow. Go ahead. Pissing contest. Oh, geez. Sorry. Anyway, that's why Scott, when he talks about these drugs, is he's pretty circumspect. Like, he'll be like, he'll name a drug and then be like, it comes to. from this, I mean, if you were potentially able to extrapolate that connotation, because nobody
因为，这是我在推测，我没有任何数据来支持这一点，但根据指导原则，你知道的，什么是最大流量，对吧？那是什么？我知道如何确定最大流量。请讲。比谁尿得远（Pissing contest）。哦，天哪。抱歉。无论如何，这就是为什么斯科特在谈论这些药物时，他非常谨慎。比如，他会说，他会给一种药物命名，然后说，它来自。从这个，我的意思是，如果你有可能推断出那种内涵，因为没有人
wants to come right out and say like, you know, take, you'll definitely sleep through the night at all. It's on sale. You know, they want some plausible deniability. Another thing the FDA very much wants to avoid is christening a new drug with a name that sounds or even looks too much like a drug that's already out there, which is a big deal in terms of our actual physical safety. Medication errors kill people, and sometimes it's because of that look-alike, sound-alike problem. And there's this sort of poster case that people
想直截了当地说，你知道，吃了这个，你绝对能一觉睡到天亮。它正在出售。你知道，他们想要一些合理的辩解空间。FDA 非常希望避免的另一件事是，用听起来或甚至看起来太像现有药物的名字来为新药命名，这在我们的实际身体安全方面是一件大事。用药错误会致人死亡，有时就是因为那种外观相似、听起来相似的问题。人们会指出关于这种混淆的典型案例。有两款药。一种叫 LASIX，L-A-S-I-X，我相信那是一种利尿剂。另一种叫 Losec，L-O-S-E-C，用于帮助溃疡和不同类型胃灼热的患者。简而言之，有一名患者住院了，大约在 80 年代末或 90 年代初，她有很多健康问题，包括溃疡，医生为她开了 Losec。但主治护士给她用了 LASIX，
point to regarding that kind of mix-up. There were two drugs. One was called LASIX, L-A-S-I-X, which I believe was a diuretic. And the other one was called Losec, L-O-S-E-C, which helped people with ulcers and different types of heartburn. In short, this one patient was admitted to the hospital, this was like the late 80s or early 90s, that had a lot of health issues, including an ulcer for which the doctor prescribed Losec. But the attending nurse gave her LASICs,
结果患者不幸去世。于是 FDA 介入并表示，你知道的，你们必须更改其中一个名字。不知怎么的，大家决定更改 LOSIC 这个名字。所以 Losek 的人找到了大卫·伍德，说我们需要这方面的帮助。大卫·伍德意识到
and the patient ultimately died. So the FDA got involved and said, you know, you got to change one of these names. And somehow it was decided that LOSIC would be the one to change. So Losek came to David Wood and said, we need this help. And David Wood realized
人们已经在 Losec 这个名字上投入了大量资金。医生们都知道它。如果发生太大的变化，医生们就不会认得它，可能就不会开这种药。公司就会失去销量。所以他做了什么呢？
that there was already a lot of investment in the name Losec. Doctors all knew it. And if there was too much change going on, doctors wouldn't recognize it, might not prescribe it. The company would lose sales. So what he did was
他让 Losek 保持不变，并加上了一个三字母的前缀。它变成了 Prilosec。哦。是的。你听说过普利赛克（Prilosec）。对，对。我觉得这是一个更好的名字。
he left Losek the same and added a three-letter prefix. It became Prylosec. Oh. Yeah. You've heard of Prilosec. Yeah, yeah. It's a better name, I think.
是的，我也这么觉得。对，Prilosec 挺管用的。我记得它。而且我不记得很多药名。对。问题是，后来 Prilosec 开始与 Prozac 混淆。哦。千真万确。
Yeah, I think so too. Yeah, Prilosec works. I remember it. And I don't remember a lot of drug names. Yeah. Problem being that then Prilosec started to become confused with Prozac. Oh. True story.
也许这就是我喜欢它的原因，因为它听起来像 Prozac。没错。还要指出的是，以 LASICS 和 LOSIC 为例，医生是手写处方的。所以这是一次视觉上的混淆，命名人员试图通过聚焦于名字的物理形状来避免这种情况。它必须有上升和下降的字母。如果没有，它就通不过审批。它必须有上升和下降的字母？
Maybe it's why I like it because it sounds like Prozac. That's right. Also to point out, with the LASICs and LOSIC example, the doctor had written a prescription by hand. So it was a visual mixup, which namers try to avoid by honing in on the physical shape of the name. It has to have ascending and descending letters. If it doesn't have that, it doesn't get approved. It has to have ascending and descending letters?
因为除此之外，名字的轮廓将是平的。描述一下这个，名字的轮廓。所以如果你想象一下倒映在河里的城市天际线，你可以认为那就是名字的外观，对吧？有摩天大楼，也有低矮的小仓库。这些都是由小写字母构成的。有些字母会突出来。比如 L、T 和 H？有些字母会往下伸。
Because other than that, the silhouette of the name would be flat. Describe this, the silhouette of a name. So if you picture like a city skyline reflected in a river, you can think of that's what the name looks like, right? There's skyscrapers and their little low warehouses. And these are all built out of lowercase letters. And you have letters that stick up. Like L, T, and H? Letters that stick down.
比如 P、Q 和 G。还有一些是平的，你知道的，比如 A、E、S 等等诸如此类的东西。如果那个轮廓只是一块像那样平的东西，那就很容易混淆。有太多其他那样平的东西了。所以你必须让轮廓在某个地方向上延伸，在某个地方向下延伸，你知道的，然后你就会得到一个不同的感知轮廓。严格来说，有些名字在没有向上突起、向下延伸的字母的情况下也能通过。但确实，这种变化在审批方面很有帮助，当你仔细想想，这也是名字如此古怪的另一个巨大原因。如果你想要一个清脆的 c 音，当然，你可以在那里用一个小写字母 C，但你也可以用一个小写字母 Q，它带有向下延伸的尾巴。
Like P, Q, and G. And letters that are flat, you know, like A, E, S and all that sort of thing. And if that silhouette was just a flat thing like that, that's easily confused. There are too many other flat things like that. So you have to have, you know, the silhouette would have something that goes up someplace, something that goes down someplace, you know, and then you get a different perceptual silhouette. Now, strictly speaking, there are names that get through without sticky up, sticky down letters. But it is true that variation helps a lot in terms of approval, which when you think about it is another huge reason why the names are so kooky. If you want a cuss sound, sure, you could use a lowercase C there, but you could also use a lowercase Q, which has the tail that sticks down.
或者不用字母 I，你可以用一个小写字母 Y。斯科特非常喜欢小写字母 Y。Y 是唯一一个具有视觉区分度特性的元音。A、E、I、O、U 都存在于同一个视觉平面上。而 Y 带着那种向下笔画的特质出现了。所以现在你看到了 TriPTier，我相信这是去年的获批产品。T-R-Y-P-T-Y-R。这在视觉上简直是双重打击的区分度。所以，是的，百分之百给我一个 B，给我一个 K，给我一个 Z，给我一个 X。那拼出来是什么？
Or instead of the letter I, you could use a lowercase Y. Scott really likes a lowercase Y. Why is the only vowel that has a visually differentiating quality to it. A, E, I, O, U all exist in the same visual plane. And here comes Y with that downstroke quality. quality to it. So now you're seeing TriP-Tier, I believe, was last year of approval. T-R-Y-P-T-Y-R. That's like a double whammy differentiation visually. So, yes, 100% give me a B, give me a K, give me a Z, give me an X. What's that spell?
是的，那个名字去年也获批了。所以把这一切结合起来，再次强调，没有夸大的承诺，没有外观或听起来相似的名字，对这些规则更严格的执行，这意味着现在的目标是在越来越多的新药不断涌现的时代里，想出完全新颖的东西。我认为，这就是药物命名的艺术性真正变得生动的地方。但让我们在这次中场休息后再讨论这个。听起来不错。
Yes, and that name was approved last year also. So putting this all together, again, no big claims, no look-alike sound-alike names, a stricter enforcement of those rules, which means the goal now is to come up with something completely novel in an age where there are more and more new drugs coming out all the time. And this, I think, is where the artistry of drug naming really comes to life. But let's talk about that after this break. Sounds good.
好的，我们回来了。肖恩，对于像斯科特和阿琳这样的人，我一直想知道的一件事是，他们是否真的知道人们在面对他们想出的这些听起来很搞笑的名字时，会有多么困惑，甚至可能觉得好笑？他们知道。好的。他们知道。我和斯科特深入讨论过这个问题。我甚至和他一起浏览了去年获批的名字清单，并说，你知道的，这个太疯狂了。
Okay, we are back. And, Sean, one of the things that I've been wondering for the sort of Scots and Arlines of the world, Do they really know how much people are scratching their heads and maybe laughing at these funny sounding names that they've come up with? They do. Okay. They do. I talked about that a lot with Scott. I even went down the list of last year's approved names with him and was like, you know, this one's crazy.
而这些都是 Brand Institute 命名的药物。我说，你知道人们把这些名字和科幻小说里的人物作比较吗？这绝对是我们在听到的一种反馈，但请理解，我们现在的处境是字母表里只有 26 个字母的结果，对吧？你必须以一种独特且具区隔度的方式将它们组合起来，并应对在全球范围内为同一个名字获得全球监管批准的途径。而这往往就是经历那个过程后产生的名字。这就是为什么当人们开玩笑说，哦，你知道，他们拿药名开玩笑时，我并不会感到太被冒犯。这就像，嗯，我完全理解。这就像挨了几记闷拳，但随后你就缓过劲来了，对吧？因为作为一名创意人员，你希望你的作品受到赞誉，每个人都喜欢它。而且你确实会得到一些一问世就成为即时热门的名字。人们立刻就喜欢念它们。然后你会得到另一些名字，没有人甚至愿意说出它。但这些都只是工作的一部分。而这确实是一份工作。但就像我一开始说的，这里面也有一种独特的艺术甚至是诗意的方面，是我没有预料到的。我认为这在我们已经讨论过的一些事情中是显而易见的，特别是关于阿琳，因为阿琳除了发明药名之外，还写俳句。她是个诗人。
And these are drugs that Brand Institute named. I'm like, are you aware that people are comparing these names to sci-fi characters? That is absolutely something that we hear, but understand that where we are is the result of there being 26 letters in the alphabet, right? And you have to combine them in a way that is distinctive and differentiating and contending with this path to a global regulatory approval for the same name across the world. And this is oftentimes the type of names that come out of that process. So that's why I don't get too offended when people say, oh, you know, they joke. about drug names. It's like, well, I completely get it. It's like a couple gut punches, but then you get over it, right? Because as a creative, you want your work to be lauded and everyone
她是个诗人。你也是吗？你是个诗人。我也是。起初，她坚称，坚称她的药物命名和写俳句没有任何关系。但最终她承认，是的，在这两项追求中，事物的声音真的很重要，也就是音调。她说，你在写俳句时应该大声朗读出来，给药名起名字时也应该这样做。它必须感觉像是适合你的嘴型。它必须在对话中流畅。所以当你告诉别人我在服用 Viagra 时，你知道的，那是一个容易说出口的句子，并不尴尬。你不会试图去说，我在服用 Imdeltra。天哪，她真的很讨厌 Mdletra 这个名字。她真的很讨厌。我会怎么做呢，我会怎么做，我会怎么做。我会把它们哼给自己听。哼出来？当然。如果一个名字能为你哼唱，如果它很容易哼唱，那就意味着它很容易发音。
to love it. And you do get names that come out and they're like instant hits. They instantly, people love saying them. And then you get other ones where nobody even wants to say it. But that's all just part of the job. And it is a job. But like I was saying at the beginning, there's also this distinct artistic and even poetic aspect to it that I wasn't expecting. that I think is apparent in some of the things we've talked about already, but especially as regards Arlene, because Arlene, as well as inventing drug names, writes haikus. She's a poet.
你是说字面意义上的哼唱。嗯，不是像歌剧那样。但是 Tougeo，Togeo。这是她正在哼唱的真实的药名吗？Tougeo？是的，那是针对糖尿病患者的胰岛素注射液。哼。我认为正是通过 Tougeo，你可以真正看到阿琳在坐下来为药物命名时思考的诗意本质。
She's a poet. As are you? You're a poet. As am I. And at first, she insisted, insisted that her drug naming and her hykooing have nothing to do with each other. But finally she conceded that, yes, in both pursuits, the sound of the things. thing is really important, the tonality. You should read your haikus out loud when you're writing them, she says, and you should do the same with a drug name. It has to feel like it fits in your mouth. It has to flow in conversation. So when you tell somebody I am taking Viagra, you know, that's an
所以解释一下你的意思。所以关于 Tougeo 的事情是，它比以前的同类药物持续时间更长。它不是 24 小时，而是可以持续约 30 小时，上下浮动。当阿琳和她的团队在进行头脑风暴时，他们开发了这个，他们有时会这样做，他们开发了一个提示。他们称之为平台，这个提示是为了即兴发挥。而提示是“你一生的朋友”。从那里，阿琳在脑海中展开了整个故事，一个关于年轻人的浪漫故事，年轻的成年人，
easy sentence to say, not awkward. It's not like you're going to try to say, I am taking Imdeltra. God, she really hates the name Mdletra. She really does. What I would do is, I would do is, I would do. I would sort of sing them to myself. Sing them? Sure. If a name can sing for you, if it's easily singable, that means it's easily pronounceable.
刚刚开始他们的成年生活。想象一下，你知道的，尤其是当他们外出从事第一份工作并结识新朋友时，总会有下班后自发调情的想法。但如果你担心必须进行下一次胰岛素注射，你就无法做到随性。除非，再次说明，那次注射持续的时间足够长，能给你晚归的自由。这样如果有人想在下班后约会，你知道的，他们只需要在凌晨 4 点之前赶回家或者做点类似的事情去注射。它会成为你一生的朋友，因为它允许你在愿意的时候享受你的夜晚。Tougeo 这个词来自海地克里奥尔语 t-O-U-J-U，它最初源于法语单词 Touzure，意思是所有日子，总是。而 Tuzhu 是它的海地克里奥尔语版本，意思是总是。所以她有整个叙事弧线，她想以某种方式用一个词，一个有音乐感的词来表达。她不需要人们知道这个故事。她只需要他们去感受它引发的共鸣。我明白了。
You're saying literally sing. Well, not like operatic. But Tougeo, Togeo. Is that a real drug name that she's singing? Tougeo? Yeah, it's an insulin shot for diabetics. Huh. And it's with Tougeo that I think
所以这才是真正的诗意所在。没错。一个完整的故事，一个完整的世界，你只需要在一个词的音乐中感受到其底层的共鸣。当你为药物命名时，而且你已经为很多药物命名过了，当它最终上市时，是什么感觉？有没有那种让你觉得，天哪，我不朽了？就像我进入了人们的千家万户。
you can really see the poetical nature of Arlene's thinking when she sits down to name a drug. So explain what you mean. So the thing about Tugeo is that it's longer lasting than a similar drug that came before it. Instead of 24 hours, it's effective for like 30 hours, give or take. And as Arlene and her team were brainstorming,
不，那种感觉不是那样的。当我最初想出这个名字并把它写在纸上时，我说，这个会是个好名字，那才是我有美妙感觉的时候。详细说说那个。嗯，这就像是一次精神高潮。你得到了一个你知道很好的东西。你知道你做过其他不是那么好的事情，而这个出现了，你知道的，当它能哼唱而且看起来很好而且会奏效，你知道的，这一切，它会让你整个人都亮起来。我的感情要内敛一些，我想说，我也更加务实一些。斯科特甚至不喜欢在这方面把自己当作一个独立的个体。
they developed this, they do this sometimes, they developed a prompt. They called it a platform, this prompt to riff off of. And the prompt was your friend for life. And from there, Arlene unspooled this whole story in her head, a kind of romantic story about young people, young adults,
就像他完全是为了团队和合作，甚至会直言不讳地说，他的快乐来自于大规模地创造出许多伟大的名字。但在他的心中，确实有那些他偏爱的名字。有时会有一个好名字，我会在心里说，那个名字怎么样了？
just beginning their adult lives. Imagine, you know, especially when they're going out to working in their first jobs and they're meeting new people, there's always the idea of afterwork the spontaneous sexual flirtation. But if you're worried about having to take your next insulin shot, you can't be spontaneous. Unless, again, that shot lasts long enough to give you the first. freedom to stay out later. So that if somebody wanted to go on a date after work, you know, they'd simply have to get home before 4 o'clock in the morning or something like that to get their
它还活着吗？它死了吗？怎么回事？我们怎么能把它留下来？哦。我确实在关注一些项目，我说，哦，这个成功了。我们确实有一款即将推出的减肥药，我对此感到非常兴奋。你能说吗？你能说吗？
shot. It'll become your friend for life because it will permit you to enjoy your evenings if you want. Tougeo came from the Haitian Creole word t-O-U-J-U, which came originally from the French word Touzure, which means all the days always. And Tuzhu was the Haitian Creole version of it, always. So she's got this whole narrative arc that she wants to express somehow in a word, in a musical word. She doesn't need people to know the story. She just needs them to feel its resonance. I see.
哦，绝对不行。我能说吗？我喜欢我的工作。不，我们确实有一两个。在减肥领域有很多事情正在发生。但是，你知道，我希望它能管用。我们在等待监管部门的反馈。所以这仍然悬而未决。而且我的脑海里甚至为它想好了一段广告歌。
So that's the real poetry of it. That's right. A whole story, a whole world, that you just. just need to feel the underlying resonance of in the music of a word. When you're naming drugs, and you've named a lot of them, how did, like, how did it feel when finally it was out on the market? Was there a thing where you're like, oh man, I'm immortal? Like I'm in people's households.
老兄，如果这个名字通过了，过後我一定会问你它叫什么名字。好的，请务必如此。我只想说这个。我只想说这个。如果这个名字获得批准，这个名字和与之相关的广告歌或歌曲将会如此显而易见，你会给我发短信。我懂的。我懂的。我就说到这里。我坐在这里，就像我从没想过的那样，期待着看到电视广告的那一刻
No, what the feeling was, not then. It was when I originally came up with the name and wrote it down on paper, and I said, this is going to be a good one, that's when I had the good feeling. Say more about that. Well, it was like a mental orgasm. You get something that you know is good. You know that you've done other things not that good,
出现一款带有其中一个名字的减肥药广告，然后我会说，就是这个。我真的很希望那发生。我也希望如此。你看，这就是为什么我们喜欢让你为这个节目做事情。这太棒了，肖恩。谢谢你。永远是我的荣幸，罗曼。本周的 99% Invisible 由肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）报道，克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）制作和剪辑，
and here comes this, and, you know, when it sings and it looks good and it's going to work, you know, and all that, it just lights you up all over. I'm a little more reserved in my feelings, I'd say, I'm also a little more pragmatic. Scott doesn't even like to talk about himself as an autonomous being in this regard.
然后这个就来了，而且，你知道，当它唱起来，看起来很棒，而且会奏效的时候，你知道，诸如此类，它会让你浑身发光。我想我在感情上要保守一点，我也更务实一点。在这方面，斯科特甚至不喜欢把自已当作一个独立的个体来谈论。
Like he's all about the team and the partnership and literally will say that he gets his pleasure out of creating a lot of great names at scale. But there are those ones, are those names, that he favors in his heart. Sometimes there's a good name, and I'll say internally, I'm like, what's going on with that name?
就像他全心全意为了团队和合作伙伴关系一样，他字面意思上说过，他的快乐来自于大规模地创造许多伟大的名字。但也有那么一些名字，是他在内心里偏爱的。有时有一个好名字，我会在心里想，那个名字怎么了？
Is it still alive? Has it died yet? What's going on? How can we keep it in? Oh. I do keep an eye on some projects, and I say, oh, that makes it. We do have one coming up for a weight loss drug that I'm very excited about. Can you say? Can you say?
它还活着吗？它死了吗？怎么回事？我们怎么能把它留下来？哦。我确实关注了一些项目，我说，哦，那个成功了。我们确实有一个即将推出的减肥药项目，我为此感到非常兴奋。你能说吗？你能说吗？
Oh, absolutely not. Can I say? I like my job. No, we do have one or two. A lot going on in the weight loss category. But, you know, I hope it works. We're waiting regulatory feedback. So it's still like up in the air. And I have a jingle in my head for it. it too. Dude, if this name passes, I am so going to ask you what it was after- back. Okay, please do.
哦，绝对不行。我能说吗？我喜欢我的工作。不，我们确实有一两个。减肥品类有很多进展。但是，你知道，我希望它能起作用。我们在等待监管部门的反馈。所以它仍然悬而未决。我脑子里甚至还有一个为它准备的jingle。老兄，如果这个名字通过了，节目结束后我一定要问你它是什么。好的，请务必如此。
And I'll just say this. I'll just say this. This name and the jingle or the song associated with it will be so obvious if and when the name gets approved, you'll text me. I get it. I get it. I'll leave it at that. And I'm sitting here like I never thought I would be, hoping for the moment that I see a TV
我只想说这个。我只想说这个。这个名字以及与之相关的jingle或歌曲，如果这个名字获得批准的话，将会是如此显而易见，以至于你会发短信给我。我懂的。我懂的。我就说这么多了。我坐在这里，就像我从未想过的那样，期待着看到电视广告的那一刻
ad for a weight loss drug. with one of those names, and I'm like, that's the one. I really hope that happens. I hope so, too. You see, this is why we love to have you do stuff for this show. This was so great, Sean. Thank you. Always a pleasure, Roman. 99% Invisible was reported this week by Sean Cole, produced and edited by Christopher Johnson,
一个关于减肥药的广告，带着其中的一个名字，我会想，就是这个。我真的希望那发生。我也希望如此。你看，这就是为什么我们喜欢让你为这个节目做点事情。这太棒了，肖恩。谢谢你。总是我的荣幸，罗曼。99% Invisible本周由肖恩·科尔报道，克里斯托弗·约翰逊制作和剪辑，
mixed by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swan Real. Fact-checking by Naomi Barr. Like I mentioned earlier, Sean is a longtime friend of the show and a friend of mine. He's been doing stories for us for like more than a decade. So go to our website and check out all of his greatest hits, including one on how to hack your Ikea furniture, the one on cow tunnels that everyone loves. They still mention it to me to this day.
由 Martine Gonzalez 混音，Swan Real 制作音乐。Naomi Barr 负责事实核查。正如我刚才所说，肖恩是节目的老朋友，也是我的朋友。他为我们做报道已经有十多年了。所以请访问我们的网站，查看他所有的经典之作，包括关于如何改装你的宜家家具的那篇，以及人人都爱的奶牛隧道那篇。至今仍有人向我提起。
And my personal favorite about the album art of Devo. Check them out. Kathy 2 is our executive producer. Kirk Colsted is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Brubé, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Lay, Lashamadon, Joe Rosenberg,
还有我个人最喜欢的关于 Devo 专辑封面的一期。请去看看吧。Kathy 2 是我们的执行制作人。Kirk Colsted 是数字总监。Delaney Hall 是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括 Chris Brubé、Jason DeLeon、Emmett Fitzgerald、Vivian Lay、Lashamadon、Joe Rosenberg、
Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, Tallinn, and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north, in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our new Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Kelly Prime、Jacob Medina Gleason、Tallinn、Rain Stradley，还有我，Roman Mars。99% 的可见标志由 Stefan Lawrence 创建。我们是 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在北边六个街区外的潘多拉大楼。位于美丽繁华的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在所有常用的社交媒体网站以及我们的新 Discord 服务器上找到我们。在那里以及 99PI.org 上有指向该服务器的链接以及 99PI 的每一期往期节目。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。